just when you thought it was safe to go
back online I'm here with another
matchup 65 million years in the making
and it features two of the all-time
baddest beasts of the big screen
and although jaws can't get credit for
most speeches being closed right now
that sharks certainly ruined many a
holiday weekend him and his glorious fin
will be going up against the gaggle of
species we thought were extinct until
dr. John Hammond and mr. DNA teamed up
to give us dinosaurs Jurassic Park is
taking on jaws to see which summer
monster spectacular reigns supreme
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter and audience score round three
characters and then we'll do a wild-card
round after which you the viewer will
have the last word the winner gets the
room in peace heretofore
the loser has to go for a ride on Ben
Gardner's boat you're ready I'm excited
and Steven Spielberg probably feels like
the mom at the end of the good son right
about now pets just kept the tickets he
can only save one anyway let's get it on
you're gonna need a bigger boat hold on
one box office I love a good box office
brawl and this one is an all-timer
we're talking about two films who anyone
who is lucky enough to see in theaters
remembers where they were when it
happened I was 12 years old when my
chubby but sneaky athletic body
warbled into the theater five times in
the summer of 1993 to see the spectacle
that was in Jurassic Park one of those
times I was with my uncle Paul who
reminded me of a similar feeling he had
in 1975 when he saw jaws the biography
of a plucky underdog shark named Bruce
just looking to feed his family
became the granddaddy of them all the
original summer blockbuster and even
though production was fraught with
delays and the film and wildly
over-budget and there were no ælis stars
in the movie once jaws hit theaters
audiences ran out of the water and into
the cinemas all told the film grossed
and adjusted for inflation 1.2 billion
dollars domestically and 2.1 billion
dollars worldwide and it became the
first
here in the States to cross the magical
hundred million dollar mark now part of
this was due to a revolutionary ad
campaign that featured Network ads the
stars doing all the talk shows and even
a run at the Cannes Film Festival to
build up word-of-mouth it will attack
and devour anything not only did that
strategy work it became the playbook
that studio still used in 2020 to garner
buzz for their summer tentpole releases
one of the most notable blockbusters in
the 45 year 45 years since jaws came out
has been Jura Sorek Park which is how my
brother pronounced it when it came out
and we will never let him forget it no
movies worked a little bit differently
once we got into the modern world of the
1990s we had newspapers and talk shows
and news reports of this movie that
Steven Spielberg was working on that
featured dinosaurs months before it came
out
and once those prehistoric creatures
were unleashed on audiences it was a
cinematic event you had to see multiple
times welcome
- Alessi Jurassic Park would gross and
adjusted 859 million dollars here in the
states and 2.2 billion dollars worldwide
and thanks to its realistic looking
creatures and having the same director
audiences noted that its shared DNA with
jaws for fun sees jaws had three sequels
and so far we have four sequels to
Jurassic Park with another one on the
way Oh Dino baby shower yay three of the
Jurassic Park sequels have crossed the
billion dollar mark at the worldwide box
office and while the jaws sequels did
make a pretty penny they never made it
back across that line but we'll get more
in depth with the sequels later in the
show I was at foreshadowing or did I
show the shark too soon I showed the
shark too soon look if we're comparing
the original Jurassic Park to the
original jaws it's a close match but
only one film invented the term
blockbuster back in 1975 jaws was
accused of saturation booking because it
had the gall to be run in 409 movie
theaters its opening weekend by the time
I got to 1993 Jurassic Park premiered on
over 2,500 screams and now big films
regularly open on over 4,000 screams the
movie that brought dinosaurs back from
extinction was engineered from the start
to be a summer tentpole extravaganza and
it did not disappoint jaws on the other
hand only cost 12 million dollars to
make even with his delayed production
costs no one knew what it was capable of
and if you claim that lucked into being
a blockbuster I would also say it
arrived at the perfect time because it
had the great recipe of a brilliant
director a heart-pounding score and a
villain who patrols a territory were all
too familiar with jaws accomplished the
rarest of feats
it made us ditch a celebrated summer
pastime swimming in the ocean and
instead had us racing into a darkened
theater to get scared about the thing we
just ditched the ocean would never be
the same
swimming would never be the same neither
with the movies Jaws you win
one that's great great round two tomato
leader and audience score sure I get a
little gushy when I talk about jaws or
Jurassic Park because they're two of my
favorite movies of all time but let's be
honest if you put a shark or a t-rex in
a movie it's gonna be successful even if
it's sharknado or if it's velociter
you're gonna have a loyal following
sharks why is it always gonna be sharks
but how do the best of the best fare on
the tomato meter good really really good
or well I don't know what the grammar is
but they're both in the 90s Jurassic
Park and jaws are certified fresh the
dinosaur movie has an A average at 91%
so I don't the world could a shark movie
with three guys on a dingy top fat they
do at 98% for jaws so it seems like an
easy win for the great fish right or is
it a mammal it's a shark no dolphins or
the man was hey remember when Crocodile
Dundee was in flipper weird right anyway
when it comes to sequels the jaws
franchise loses the Jurassic Park with
the dinos average beating out the toothy
swimmers 63% to 42% but more on the
sequels wait damn it I showed the shark
again down Bruce so again why is this
not an easy win for Jaws let's take a
look at that audience score according to
the people Jurassic Park gets a slight
edge with a tight 91% to 90% victory not
sure maybe you can argue that most of
the 2020 audience had the advantage of
seeing Jurassic Park when it was fresh
in theaters and they might have only
seen jaws when it aired on TNT quick
sidebar jaws is on TNT like all the time
it still plays there a lot why does Ted
Turner love shark so much anyway I'll
counter that argument by reminding
everyone that Jurassic Park was born
into a world we were already had tons of
great blockbusters so the expectations
for critics and audiences might have
been loftier than they were back in 1975
any way you slice it it's a close match
both great films I like jaws better but
the people have spoken and they say
Jurassic Park by a nose
and the kitchen loving Raptors win round
two we're tied up I'm simply saying that
life finds a way round three character
funny thing about both these movies the
monster a creature angle might have been
what lured us into the theater to see
these movies opening night but I'd argue
it's the human performances that keep us
coming back for more
after all what good is a great white
shark without the tension without the
dynamic of three fellas from very
different walks of life going after it
together and dinosaurs are cool but
they're better when we're rooting for
our beloved human pals to survive unless
they're warriors when you gotta go you
gotta go and the only one I've got on my
side is the blood sucking lawyer I still
don't think Roy Scheider Richard
Dreyfuss or Robert Shaw get enough
credit for how great they are in Jaws
I mean you have the water-resistant
Chief of Police the excitable young
college boy scientists and the salty
veteran fisherman looking for the
ultimate prize the way that that film
establishes the variant personalities
and then slowly unites them in pursuit
of a common enemy is nothing short of
masterful storytelling yeah but I'm not
drunk enough to grab the boat yes you
are yes you are can't do that yes you
can when we first see them all together
who could have predicted that in an hour
we all be singing a sea shanty together
farewell then adieu Spanish ladies you
think the think the shark could hear
them singing and was waiting for them to
start before attacking the boat it's a
theory Mike it's a smart fish fast and
smart
[Applause]
Jurassic Park takes it a step further we
have very personalities but we also have
three generations of human factoring
into the Dino Adventure dr. John Hammond
is the lovable grandpa who created this
amusement park and it was in part to
bring him closer to his grandkids Lex
and Tim not only are Lexington added
incentive for the adults in the room to
be protective but they also contribute
both are crafty Alexis computer hacking
skills saved the day and Tim he's got
great jokes
Wein dinosaur let's we bury the lede we
also have a prehistoric expert who hates
smelly babies they smell dr. Alan Grant
and his love interest who is a plant
expert dr. Ellie Sattler
and her off-screen real-life love
interest for a time dr. Ian Malcolm a
mathematics rockstar cat is a chaotic
frankly Jeff Goldblum gets the
Brachiosaurus his share of the memorable
lines but all three leads are so well
fleshed out that we care about the fate
of each one and as the events of the
film forced them all to separate it
creates an edge of your seat viewing
experience that does not let up the
genius of Jaws is that these three boys
are stuck together for much of the film
you think it's rough being quarantined
with your two roommates who always eat
the cheese it's that you bought try
spending multiple days on the Orca with
this motley crew watch warriors and jaws
is anything but a three-person show
Lorraine Gary adds valuable screen time
to help us appreciate what matters most
chief Brody his family and I'd also like
to introduce your MVP Mayor Vaughn
Murray Hamilton is so good as the
economic minded mayor the decades since
he bungled the Amity fourth of July
celebration he's a constant presence on
social media every time a real-life
politician does something stupid which
is often Jurassic Park counters with the
bumbling nefarious Dennis Nedry
the badass tone legged hunter Muldoon
and samuel l.jackson zarnold who gave us
all a very accurate piece of advice
heading into the movie hold on to your
books and every great movie needs a
scene with a lawyer dying on the toilet
so props to Gennaro for giving us all Oh
laughs my audience actually cheered the
first time I saw this movie when he got
eaten they went crazy I was right there
with them speaking of getting eaten how
about the characters that are actually
featured on their own movie posters the
dinosaurs in Jurassic Park and with all
due respect to Chrissy the shark from
Jaws while the great fin one doesn't
have much to say I find its persistence
admirable but that's just one shark
whereas off the coast of Costa Rica
there's a bevy of dinosaurs that run the
gamut from friendly to menacing then you
have ones that appear to be friendly but
they're actually medicine and then the
t-rex
has personality to burn and rounds out
an all-star cast jaws has a core that
will stand the test of time throughout
the ages but if we're looking for great
characters top to bottom
Jurassic Park gets the nod team dinosaur
has taken its first lead over the Amity
sharks the crazy side and now it's time
for the wild-card round
legacy the very fact that we're bringing
up these movies a combined 67 years
after their initial release is proof
enough that they have quite the legacy
but which film casts a taller shadow
over Tinseltown let's first take a look
at their respective franchises that they
spawned both were profitable but
Jurassic Park got a huge shot in the arm
from recent offerings Jurassic world and
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom world went
on to be the first film to gross at
least 200 million dollars in its opening
weekend and all told the five films to
date and the Jurassic Park franchise
have grossed 2.7 seven billion dollars
domestically and 7.21 billion dollars
internationally the four jaws movies
can't compete with those Scrooge McDuck
dollars but at least they did what
sequels are supposed to do they got
worse and worse with every outing if
that shopkin Texas agenda was gonna feed
that big boy a meal he won't forget jaws
2 is watchable jaws 3d was hilarious in
1987 jaws The Revenge had a great white
shark so pissed at the Brody family
it swam from the Northeast and the
tropical Bahamian waters just to finish
them off can sharks even survive and
water that warm the more I think about
this movie the more I realize its
greatness Lorraine Gary returns as Ellen
Brody Michael Caine shows up and we get
a young Mario Van Peebles this is Oscar
gold the shark has ESP of course
Jurassic Park 3 had talking dinosaurs
these are both Universal properties
right do I smell a crossover no there it
is ok look it's fair to say the sequels
will never outshine the original so
let's take a look at their respective
legacies through a different lens for
Jurassic Park it might be the single
most
important film post Star Wars in terms
of special effects in fact it wasn't
until George Lucas saw what his buddy
Steven Spielberg was doing on set of
Jurassic Park that he became confident
he could tell his prequel stories the
way he wanted
Spielberg's revolutionary use of
practical effects mixed with next-level
CGI opened the floodgates for filmmakers
to climb to the farthest heights of
their imaginations and assured that they
would never have to be handcuffed the
way that Spielberg himself was on the
set of Jaws that movie serves as
something of a counter punch to Jurassic
Park
sometimes a filmmaker will have to adapt
to seemingly unfavorable conditions and
find clever workarounds initially the
shark was to be shown on screen much
much more however in retrospect wouldn't
that have dulled the impact every time
we do see it in the final cut
unfortunately jaws also has a darker
legacy it vilified great white sharks
and made them a prime target for
poachers looking for a prized trophy
even the author of the novel Peter
Benchley later regretted his work due to
the massive harm it had on the shark
community be that as it may it's not a
totally fair comparison because
dinosaurs are extinct so we don't know
how they would have fared but I'm
betting Joe xotic would have bought a
couple and Carol Baskins husband
probably would have had a different
faith let's just all agree to treat real
great white sharks as majestic creatures
if they are and leave them alone the
bottom line is without Jaws we don't get
a Jurassic Park or possibly an Indiana
Jones of Star Wars and et a deep blue
sea and we all need that movie we prefer
it was the cultural landmark event that
all future blockbusters needed in order
to live I'm talking about jaws not deep
blue sea jaws set the tone for movies in
terms of release date advertising poster
artwork and it gave a shot in the arm to
the career of a 27 year old Bunder con
director who would go on to make
gigantic flicks for decades to come both
films have been referenced countless
times in pop culture they're high on
virtually every popular movie list and
made enough cash to sink a boat or buy
an island but in terms of legacy jaws is
bite is just a little bit bigger don't
believe me just ask Quinn sorry
jaws wins the round and we're all tied
up well - you finish finish ladies
yes we're all tied up so now I have to
use my tiny human brain to render a
verdict in a clash of two of the
greatest Creature Features ever put the
celluloid so let me borrow another human
brain to help out our expert researcher
mark Hoffmeyer took a look at a gaggle
of best movie lists from various
publications the lower the score the
better kind of like in golf so in his
tabulation jaws earned a total of 22
points - Jurassic Park 78 that's the way
I'm gonna lean simply because I think
jaws is a slightly better movie JP has
better sequels there's no doubt about it
but for all the wondrous effects and
spectacle and storytelling in Jurassic
Park there's something so pure and
simple about jaws it's three dudes
versus a shark and in that simplicity
live so many keys to filmmaking
engaging in audience sustaining suspense
and building to a satisfying climax and
the mute the music do I not have more
rounds for the music the John Williams
is not bad
the Jurassic Park score isn't endlessly
familiar nod to the wonderment of when
the world was new but going back to
simplicity
[Music]
all he needed was just those two notes
to capture the essence of Jaws and it's
those two notes that every single one of
us thinks up every time we think it's
safe to go in the water the ocean the
pool the bathtub jaws and the music is
right there with us and it always will
be
congratulations Bruce you win swim down
to the Bahamas and celebrate oh boys I
think he's coming back for his noon
feeding now it's your turn faithful
viewer vote below in the comment section
and let us know which movie or which
movie franchise you prefer better and
then defend your reason with vigor I'm
not gonna waste my time arguing with a
man who's lining up to be a hot lunch
I'm gonna see you later
hey go as long as you in the comment
section because her and I have nothing
better to do than read each and every
one of us we hope you're staying safer
in this trying time and if anyone out
there has the cure for kovat 19 I would
love to believe you and then I quote the
greatest mayor in American history you'd
love to prove that wouldn't you get your
name in the national dish
[Music]
[Applause]